tomlin may eventually see the coach of
the year award we're going to draft the
top candidates
next here comes the trivia question for
chris lamar jackson is owen six in his
career when trailing by two scores in
the second half of a game which current
quarterback and future hall of famer
started his career
oh and 26 when down by two scores in the
second half i i believe this is drew
brees because i remember seeing it a few
weeks ago and i think he got his no damn
who is it
current quarterback and future hall of
famer oh it's aaron rodgers
yes
yes it is man i should have known that
one
yeah
all right i get the first pick and
coach of the year is
a fascinating award because
it goes to the coach whose team
typically
whose team best exceeds whatever the
loosely held expectations were entering
the season right right so it's a sliding
scale it depends upon where you were
supposed to be and where you finish yes
and right now yeah where are you going
to go here this is interesting because
there's some there's some good ones this
year
right now i'm going to start with brian
flores ah dolphins have done the past
several weeks sorry sorry damn you
yeah first pick brian flores right now
if i had to vote coach of the year it
would be him where they are right now in
relation to where they were supposed to
be yeah that question and the switch and
the switch from from fits magic to tua
has worked out perfectly right and he's
a defensive coach and they're winning
games with their defense i mean you know
and not totally but every game they make
a few plays or whatever else to where
you go wow you know he's he's really
you know toyed and messed with some
offensive coordinators of late some of
the things he's done schematically and
you know i'm with you that would have
been my number one pick i think i'm
going to go with mike tomlin though
that's going to be the next one i don't
really you know i know we thought
pittsburgh was any good nobody thought
they were going to be 9-0 i that's
that's a no negative ghost rider and the
fact that he can kind of you know keep
that team on edge all the personalities
you know big ben coming off injury
everything that has surrounded that
football team
uh i i gotta give mike t mike tomlin a
lot of credit for what he's doing there
in pittsburgh he probably doesn't get
enough credit in total what he's done
there in pittsburgh but this is a pretty
special year right now
there had been a belief the steelers
could be really good this year i agree
with you no one was thinking they would
be the last undefeated team standing i
still think that what's going on this
year
had its roots in last year when they
lost ben roethlisberger and they never
gave up and they kept fighting and
fighting and fighting i think that
spirit carried over now bends back and
they've got that mentality
that you know that that they are
fighting uphill every week and i think
that's one of the reasons why they've
won every single game next one for me i
gotta go with kevin stefanski the browns
head coach at six and three the browns
have won six games from 2015 through
2017 they were four and 44
and now they're six and three are you
kidding me so uh and and we were both
like ah they should have hired josh
mcdaniels or as stefanski wasn't a play
caller long enough it's worked out well
and even without otto beckham jr they're
winning the games they're supposed to
win they got to do something about
winning the games they're not supposed
to win but they don't lose sight of what
they need to do to beat the teams
they're supposed to beat and under that
standard they should finish 10-6 chris
yeah uh i i mean you're right and of
course it is special
so they've been irrelevant for so long
and the fact that they are playing the
way they are and seem to have a belief
and just a
a way they want to play every week uh
that goes all to kevin stefanski so um
you're right he was i don't know if he's
going to be my next pick i think i was
gonna take i'm gonna take cliff
kingsbury i think he's the guy i'm going
with next you know we talked about it a
little bit i mean they had the number
one pick in football and just two drafts
ago and now here we are going whoa
you know mike florio's on the bandwagon
they're six and three the number three
seed in the nfc i mean they got it all
going and one of the reasons they got it
all going is because that quarterback
they got at kyla murray and
kingsbury is a huge important part of
them acquiring him you know i don't know
if they have cl if they don't have cliff
kingsbury if they just cut the cord on
the josh rosen experiment and go there
but we know cliff kingsbury and i know
just from personal conversations has
thought kyla murray was a freak for like
seven years now and he finally got his
hands on him so he couldn't wait so part
of their success is yes the way he's
coaching the team the fact that he got
kyler murray there they are relevant
they're fun to watch
and he's adjusting to nfl life too i
mean look at all the runs they had last
week that was that was good i mean i'm
impressed with the adjustments he's made
you know slowly but surely from college
in the nfl so i'll give kingsbury my
next vote
yeah i was seriously considering him
this last one for me is very difficult
yeah it's tough one here
i'm gonna go with sean payton okay
when he when he hasn't had michael
thomas
he didn't have emmanuel sanders for a
couple of weeks
drew brees does not have that live down
the field arm that's well established
and it's funny just because they win a
few games oh there goes that narrative
no he still can't throw the ball deep
just because they're winning they're
winning you know the defense hasn't been
spectacular and and the the fact that
they so badly outclassed the tampa bay
buccaneers
when everything was pointing toward the
buccaneers winning that was impressive
so uh you know i i think peyton has been
underappreciated because of those three
weird years 2013 2014 2015
uh
really into 2016 right they the defense
was so bad nothing he did offensively
was going to make a difference because
of that lost year of 2012 where he was
suspended and and they were dealing with
the bounty scandal it took him a while
to build it back up but look at what
they've done in recent years and i think
we shouldn't take good teams for granted
when they continue to be good because i
think this year there's enough factors
that maybe the saints shouldn't be
anywhere close to having the kind of
record they currently have yeah well
unfortunately he's such a good coach
yeah he kind of gets screwed over a lot
of years that's you know that's that's
the problem it really is and he's he is
he's phenomenal he should be in this
conversation every year and down to the
final ones at least the last few years
certainly man i'm torn here
really between
i'm down to like bruce arians and gruden
i'm not sure which way i'm going to go
here i'm surprised you know i was i was
torn between peyton and andy reid
go ahead uh i'm gonna go with gruden i'm
gonna give gruden some love here i am
you know again the raiders were not a
good football team he's taken over
they've built something derek carr is
having a good year they got a top
rushing attack they've beaten some
really good teams in football this year
if they sneak in the playoffs if they
beat the chiefs this week we're going to
be really talking about john gruden so
i'll give my old man johnny gruden some
love
it may not be a good thing to win this
award two of the last five have been
fired ron rivera in 2015 won it was
fired last year jason garrett won it in
2016 and was fired
and some would say maybe matt nagy who
won it just two years ago
so it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports